straight away when when movement stops
open my eyes and the first thing i did
under the seat belt try to remove the
wheel it was gone
so at least one last concern and then
try to jump out
seconds but for me it looks more like
one minute thirty and you will see
through the explanation so
it stops i open my eyes under the seat
belt
sting will go on and i leave i want to
jump out and
i hit something on top of my helmet i
feel i hate something so i sit back down
that's how
i must be upside down against the
barrier so i will uh i will wait that
they come and help me
so i sit back down and i look at my
right and i look on the left and then
they say oh it's all orange
that's strange few things is it sunset
no it's not sunset
it's the light from the secrets no also
the
off starts to melt so oh it's fire okay
no i don't have time that um
they come so this time i try to go up a
bit more to the right
doesn't work go back down try a bit more
to the left it doesn't work so i sit
back down and
then there's a bit of swearing going on
and i said no i can't
i can't finish like this i can't finish
i thought about nikki lauda because to
me it was
it's funny is the the one that the
driver that i love the most to his story
of formula one
and i said no no i can't finish like
nikki can't finish like this cannot be
my last race
it can't not be my last race so i try
again
i'm stuck and there and then comes the
path which is the less
funny one funny isn't the word but the
most scary one is
is i sit back down all my muscle relaxes
almost no other smile but in peace with
myself
thinking i'm dead i will die and then i
thought
which parts can i burn first is it the
food is it the hands is it going to be
painful
very very strange feeling you know i
think
you know sometimes we we are close to
death we're a bit scared
this time death for me was was here and
then i named it bonua
don't ask me why i just i just had to
put a name on it and
and i'll call it burn one and then and
then
i don't know if that moment allowed me
to recover a bit get my
brain try to find another solution i
thought about my kids and i said no
i cannot die today for my kids i cannot
i've got to see them
and then i had the idea to to twist my
head like this
go up and turn my body and it works but
then my foot is stuck on the on
the pedal so i've got to go back down in
the car
pull as hard as i can on my on my left
leg
i mean the shoe stayed where my foot was
and my foot
came out and then i'd do it again and i
went through and the shoulder went
through and at the time i knew the
shoulder
had passed the halo part i was going to
leave
you know i have i know i've got two of
my hands on the fire
on the halo i can i can see my gloves
they're red normally they
start going full black and i can feel
the pain
and the burn but i'm going up
then i jump on the barrier and then i
feel he and that pulls on my
on my overall and then
that is an extraordinary feeling